the continuing fight for social justice
is leading many americans to try and
better understand
our nation's often painful past it is
also giving new life to community
efforts to preserve black cemeteries
really excited about the story congress
is considering legislation
that would create a database of burial
sites
and provide funding to research and
protect them this could bolster
cemetery restoration projects across the
country
including one from cbs news producer
rodney hawkins who we know and love he
is embarking on a journey
to reclaim his family legacy
deep in the piney woods of east texas
beneath this roughly 200 year old
overgrown cemetery
is my family history and a part of
america's very past
i had to work the fields just like
everybody else i'd pick cotton
you didn't grow up during slavery why
were you picking cotton well my dad
that was part of what he did to make a
living for the family
curling curl heard or as i call her
granny
was born in 1946 on a sharecropping farm
her parents michinova curl raised 12
children in this tiny house in
nacogdoches the oldest city in texas
on their more than 100 acres we still
own
most of the land what would you think
your parents would think of
us their legacy coming back and still
appreciating this
you know what i think they would be so
proud not far from our property
we found our family cemetery in disarray
it's tragic to see this cemetery in this
state
as painful as it can be to uncover the
past
it's important my ancestors our
ancestors
are honored it needs a lot of work my
cousins rayford and nell coleman
want to make sure that happens i've been
through chemo
radiation in 2016 i had a stroke
death has hit me right in the face we
all need to think about how we want our
family
to not forget us what goes through your
mind thinking
that possibly the legacy of this
cemetery
may have been forgotten that's why i'm
talking to you rodney
you're the young generation and my kids
we have to make them aware
of the history before us
that importance is not lost on me
particularly this year as a journalist
revisiting the 1921 race massacre and
covering stories of
heartbreaking loss we had to reclaim
this cemetery to not lose
our history the state officially
registered old mount gillian this summer
with the help of archie ricin it's ugly
history
but it's necessary that we talk about it
he's devoted his retirement to restoring
historically black cemeteries
why are you getting emotional
i'm connecting myself to my past
a lot of people by the black folks can't
do that and some
they tell me my friends they don't want
to he says some
want to forget the pain and shame of
this country's past
when slaves were freed they
knew the pains that our ancestors went
through
and the biggest thing on their minds was
survival
rayson introduced me to perky bison we
don't have marble
like this in texas a history professor
at stephen f austin university
who works with the texas historical
commission to preserve cemeteries it's
going to soak up
the water baisel and her students joined
us to start the restoration
a year-long project this was well done
she says this simple tombstone from my
great great grandfather
bill curl whose parents were enslaved
has great significance
so this says more than at rest with all
the symbols that are around it
this is a true sign to anybody walking
by
this is an important person that
importance hit my granny oh yeah just
12.
lovely emotional every memorial day they
cleaned up the cemetery
but she hadn't been back here in over 40
years
and you don't think that when you're
growing up the value
right or what your parents are teaching
you until now
you look back it was wonderful
now that you're able to reflect and see
what all they have yes
and the little that they made yes out of
nothing
we're restoring this old cemetery thank
you so much
to show gratitude to those that came
before us
[Music]
oh my god as we unravel their history
waiting
just beneath the surface for cbs this
morning rodney hawkins
nacogdoches texas wow well done rodney
hawkins and to hear
him say or when he was asking um his
relative why are you getting so
emotional i'm connecting myself to my
past and a lot of people
a lot of black people in particular
can't always do that right
it's so important that he's doing this
work honoring our ancestors
and rodney is a colleague and friend of
all of ours
we're so proud of him with an incredible
piece i spoke to him last night he said
that he has leads
on who the descendants of his ancestor
slave owners might be
that's awesome we're living right now so
definitely more to come to this story
i'm sure
first of all well told yes and second of
all i hope this inspires
other people rodney thanks to your story
to go look into their family's past
as well i think it will look forward to
seeing more of that
on today's cbs this morning podcast you
could hear more of that
by going to this podcast and hear from
rodney about his journey and what led
him
to share his family's story